[Music]
thank you for joining us today and today
my colleague Wyatt and I are going to
talk about a high-performance computing
on Google cloud my name is Emma
I'm a developer kit for Google cloud
platform
so we have four chapters today the first
part is we like about reviewing what HPC
is and what it means on cloud and then
we like to talk about some of the cloud
offerings we have for HPC applications
then why are we be discussing job
management on cloud and some of the real
world case studies so let's take a close
look at what HPC is and what it means on
cloud high-performance computing or HPC
is generally characterized as massively
parallel and with a lot of data so
massive rural means a lot of course from
10,000 cores and sometimes hundreds of
thousand cores and a lot of data usually
means petabytes sometimes exabytes of
data HPC is one of the most important
area in computer science it powers a lot
of different industry such as scientific
simulations engineering and financial
services health and life science and
data analysis and more so these are just
a few examples but when you think of
high-performance computing there are
actually two slightly different types of
workloads the first kind or the first
type is high throughput or what we call
embracing leap parallel computing so
these types of workloads are relatively
independently working on each of those
so they communicate less often or less
often between nodes the example types of
workloads include financial services
genomics media transcoding rendering and
data analysis so these types workload
just works fine on cloud day and there
are a lot of examples
the other type of workload is tightly
coupled or just parallel computing this
is more of the traditional area area in
high-performance computing applications
might use MPI as a programming interface
they often communicate between nodes so
they require low latency high bandwidth
network and of course they also require
a lot of stretch and they must be fast
enough so this is more about scientific
engineering completion example use cases
like computing computational fluid
dynamics electronics engineering product
design and gas research without physical
chemistry and we actually have a lot of
real use cases and customers running
these these two types of workloads
including the high throughput computing
and tightly coupled computing and while
I'll be showcasing some of the examples
after during this talk HPC requires a
quite different kind of infrastructure
when compared to web applications or
mobile backends of course it requires a
strong computation power and a lot of
storage and as they communicate between
nodes they require low ratings in high
bandwidth network and as we we will need
to manage a lot of nodes we need some
sort of software and to manage these HPC
deployments and of course we need to
because friendly why would we need to
use cloud or migrate to cloud well in
the world of on-premise HPC clusters we
usually have relatively smaller number
of configurations for example we might
have a single configuration mode with
CPUs and GPUs and the same amount of
memory for
all of the notes so they usually have
one a few cues so all of the users have
to use the same configuration same note
and same with cue sometimes these
machines are too big or too small for
these workloads so there are some
computation resources that left unused
but will cloud you can configure as many
clusters or as many kills as we as you
need and on top of that you can resize
these virtual machines as necessary and
assess these or GPS that necessary for
example if some of your users need just
appears we can set a precursor which
CPUs and if another user might need GPUs
we can add GPUs just for the user so
these are more resource efficient and
cost efficient and of course these
clusters can be scaled in and out as
necessary and we can go even further for
example when your task needs exactly 20
CPU and 46 gigabyte memory we can
provision virtual machines of the exact
size we call it customer scene types
we'll explain later but this is the idea
of having virtual machines and
computation nodes on cloud so let me
introduce some of the cloud offerings we
have for HPC applications
compute engine so compute engine is one
of the most fundamental components on
Google cloud there are high performance
virtual machines with access to the
latest generations of hardware including
Intel skylake processors and any video
about LG peers they are very easy to
provision they can be started in within
10 seconds or 20 seconds so when you're
studying hundreds nodes are they
they will be ready within a minute and
we have the web interface command-line
utility and where we API so you can
start using the cloud with the web
interface and when you need to automate
certain tasks you can migrate to other
methods to control the Europe cluster of
course we take security very very
seriously we have more than 750
engineers and security experts working
to protect our infrastructure they're
not only working on the software we run
on on our platform but also the hardware
network and physical infrastructure so
they are designing and engineering all
aspects of our platform and we use the
same network we have one of the
strongest network for public cloud
providers with the same network for
Google cloud that we use for our
services like YouTube such maps and
other old our other applications so
running your application on Google cloud
means you will be benefited is
benefiting from the network and
infrastructure that we use to run our
services these are some of the numbers
and details so computer engine is very
flexible from one chord to one and 60
cores and you can scale up to nearly 4
terabytes of memory and you can of
course a touch GPS and the SSDs as
necessary and you can configure
plentiful VMs on GPS are these our
mechanism to save costs I will explain
this part more in detail later since
this is very flexible you can install
any operating systems or any software
that you need to run your software so
computing can be used for MP
applications but ATC applications
real-time processing MapReduce and
machine learning work roles so this is
very flexible having access to the
latest generation of hardware is even
more important will cloud with Intel
skylake CPUs your application might run
faster by up to 82% with access to the
avx-512 instructions shorter runtime
means not only you get your results
faster but also you can terminate these
instances passed earlier so you don't
have to pay for the other in time and
wasted computing resources we have GPS
as well you can touch up to 8 GPUs per a
virtual machine they are directly
attached to these virtual machines via
PCI Express so they are close to the
bare metal performance and GPS or GP is
all support printables on virtual
machines we offered our nvidia tesla k
ATP 100 the latest voter will be 100 we
have a couple of block storage options
the first option is the local SSD they
are directly attached to the virtual
machines they are ephemeral
so when virtual machines are terminating
the data on the district will be lost
but it is very fast with 680 cubes for
read and 2.5 gigabits per second of
throughput you can touch up to 3
terabytes of SSDs to a single instance
this is best to be used for temporary
data and thus freeing frequently
accessed crush space
we also have persistent disks with SSDs
and
hdds so as the name implies these are
persistent so even when virtual machines
are terminated the data will be kept
with SSD we assist either best for
latency sensitive applications and data
they they have up to 40 K read I ops and
800 megabytes per read of throughput how
disks are very cost effective it is best
suited for latency insensitive test and
lots of data both of these persistent
disks can be scaled up to 64 terabytes
per instance and we offer other features
such as snapshots encryptions and others
to protect your data we also for objects
object storage which cloud storage for
large unstructured data
these can scale up to extra bytes and
can be accessed from any of the virtual
machines and even up from outside the
Google cloud platform with the rest
interface the latency with the object
storage is higher than persistent disks
so they are more suited for about kind
of operations we offer products
compliant strange with GCS you so you
can direct so you can mount these
storage buckets from your Linux
instances
we have some of the best networks you
can launch up to 7000 virtual machines
in a single Network and they have
relatively predictable
low latency between nodes with 40 to 60
microseconds the bandwidth depends on
the number of scores well they can scale
up to 16 bits per second so this is
faster than taking a bit Ethernet and in
order to achieve this performance we
design our decent bit center network
from scratch we have closed topology
network so that these nodes can
communicate to other nodes we go
relatively regardless of their physical
positions not only the intro dead center
network we also have a global Google
Network so you be seeing this big
diagram before I think but these blue
lines are existing cables that Google
use uses and these green lines are new
optic fiber cables the cables that we
invest in and build with our partners so
when you are working with other
institutions and working on
international projects you can move your
data from one continent to another we
offer options to save cost custom
machine types we talked about this
briefly before this is a mechanism to
pick on any configuration that matches
your workloads this is as easy as moving
these slides on the web interface you
can choose from one chord to 106 scores
very easily by moving this slide and the
same for the memory our customers have
said on average of
percent or up to 50 percent by using
custom machine types so if this is about
choosing the right size of washing
machines for your pros
these numbers are form the real customer
experience customer examples and we also
offer pre-emptive virtual machine
instances they are discounted by up to
80 percent so they're super low cost
short term instances so they might get
preemptively so then they have the
maximum lifetime of 24 hours they might
run up to 24 hours but they are not
guaranteed to be alive for 24 hours we
might have to terminate them but they
are discounted in return and we have
reduced pricing for a touch resources
such as local SSDs and
GPUs so they if you run preemptable VMS
you're touched resources are also
discounted and we even with printable
VMs you have access to the same set of
hardware that we offer for regular VMs
so this is best best suited for relative
shorter lifetime tasks and high perform
high throughput computing or high
independent jobs kind of tasks they can
either be studied again from scratch or
can be resumed from checkpoints so if
even if you have to run the same task
again they are discounted father so in
total you can save cost now I'd like to
welcome wired to talk about your
management and real use cases on cloud
hi everybody
Thank You Emma so Emma's just given us a
great overview of the infrastructure
that we could use to build high
performance
computing clouds so I want to talk now
about how we can run and manage jobs on
those high-performance computing
clusters in the cloud what software we
can use I want to give you all a couple
of opportunities to get your hands dirty
so if you want to take your laptops out
I have a couple of links so you can load
up some code labs and tutorials and then
I want to talk about some real-world
customer use cases where we've seen our
customers running their high performance
computing applications in the cloud so
we have a number of workload management
partners so first of all what is a
workload manager in high-performance
computing in traditional
high-performance computing a workload
manager their job is pretty much limited
to managing resources and allocating
jobs throughout a cluster right so that
means that you build your cluster you
configure it with your operating system
everything like that and then you
install a workload manager on top of
that and then you use that workload
manager to submit jobs and that workload
manager allocates those jobs throughout
the cluster to manage those resources
and and best bin pack it's called right
so in the cloud the role of a workload
manager expands a little bit often and
so they often take on the responsibility
of building the cluster provisioning the
nodes configuring the nodes even and
everything like that those are the sorts
of things that you can't do with
hardware right in software so they even
extend off into scheduling maintenance
tasks and tearing down nodes as needed
so we have a number of partners as I
said I want to just focus on three of
them today so the three we have today
are all tears PBS cloud IO this is a
really easy to use web-based management
system we have scheduled you slurm and
we also have HT Condor so for the people
who are here who's used these pieces of
software somewhere on-premise already
just a few people great this is an intro
course so you're all in the right place
who's used it on the cloud though any of
these pieces of software a couple of
hands went up that didn't go up earlier
that's great warms my heart so I'm
hoping to get everybody's hands up by
the end of this because we have a couple
of tutorials and code labs we can do so
first of all is all tears PBS cloud for
anybody who isn't familiar with Altair
they're a company that develops software
for things like computational fluid
dynamics structural simulations for
Engineering crash simulations and
automotive and and you know military
uses so they have this suite of software
and they really wanted to build a system
that would allow their customers to run
these jobs very easily using the cloud
resources right so what they built was
PBS cloud dot IO and they built it on
GCP so PBS cloud IO like I said is a
very simple to use web-based GUI where
you can log in when you log in you
provide a Google cloud platform billing
ID so that's the only tie back you
really have to Google cloud to know that
you're running on Google cloud so you
provide this billing ID and then you get
a menu of possible solvers altaïr
software and others and you can provide
your input data you can provide the way
you want the job to scale any limits or
anything like that you want to apply and
click launch and it'll go and spin up
the nodes it'll show you that it's
spinning them up configuring them and
then actually allocating your job across
those nodes tear the whole thing down
once it's done provide your output data
into a Google Cloud Storage bucket for
example right so this is a really really
easy way to get started with some
workloads that you already have that are
that are independent right so you can go
and log on to PBS cloud IO today provide
your billing ID and start launching jobs
right so that's a very simple way to get
to get going that's not typical in HPC
though so slurm is another more
traditional HPC workload manager it's
very popular it's open source it's used
in some of the largest high-performance
computing clusters in the world and so
we partnered with scat MD who are the
developers and maintainer z' of slurm to
bring google cloud native functionality
and integrations into the slurm workload
manager and so we announced this at
supercomputing is 2017
these integrations are available on
github so if you wanted to google them
right now you could go and look at all
the code and so there are three ways to
use these integrations the first is a
standalone auto-scaling cluster in the
cloud the second is a burst of cloud use
case where you have an existing
controller as an existing slurm cluster
and you can actually spin up just
independent VMS in a cloud project and
run jobs on them as needed and the third
is a federated to cloud use case that's
really popular and I'll talk about the
cloud auto-scaling in federates cloud a
little bit more but for anybody who
wants to get started this is the link
right there you can load that up that's
a codelab
a Google code lab that will guide you
through setting up a project downloading
the the slurm integrations and
configuring them and launching a cluster
and then even scaling it to meet demand
or you could search Google slurm code
lab where they got that got your
pictures great so it's just down here at
the bottom if anybody needs as well so
in a cloud auto-scaling
implementation it's a like I said a
standalone cluster in the cloud so what
does that mean it means you have a login
node as is traditional in any HPC
cluster you want an independent login
node that isn't actually doing any work
so that if it goes down when your SSH
into it for some reason
nothing's affected so you have a login
node a controller node that's the node
that's actually running the slurm
controller the slurm database the slurm
accounting daemon and everything like
that that everything reports back into
to get its job allocation and then you
have the compute nodes right so all of
these are running on Google compute
engine and so the cloud the cluster auto
scale is according to two parameters it
scales up and down so the parameters are
first job requirements so if any one job
is submitted that needs more resources
than the cloud then the cluster
currently has it'll spin up resources to
accommodate that
so for example if you had a cluster of
two nodes to compute nodes for example
and you submitted a single job that
required four nodes it'll spin up those
two additional nodes integrate them into
the cluster and allocate the job to
those four nodes right the second is
queue depth so this isn't something that
a lot of people think about very often
but if you were to submit say for single
node jobs right each job only requiring
at most one node then a workload manager
might just allocate them all to the same
node depending on your over subscription
settings and slurm though you can scale
to meet that so those four jobs would
spin up an additional two nodes to meet
the four nodes that were required by
each of those four jobs right it's a
very dynamic scaling to meet
requirements and then like I said it
spins them down as well afterwards so
according to an adjustable idle timeout
the nodes will be deep provisioned and
deleted in google cloud after the nodes
are idle so that you're not paying for
any unneeded unnecessary usage or
compute time the best part of all of
this is that once you deploy the slurm
cluster in the cloud for anybody who's
used slurm before it's the same tools
that you use before it's the same tools
that your users and admins are used to
so it's really easy to get started the
second use case is the federate - cloud
use case this is where we see a lot of
customers going for their bursts - cloud
needs so in a slurm Federation you're
able to add multiple clusters into
what's called a Federation and
distribute jobs amongst them right so
you combine all of these clusters you
actually use a single accounting master
server for all the slurm accounting
which makes things like erm you know
account management as well as job
placement policies and things like that
which are very powerful in slurm makes
it really easy to manage all of those
from a single master server and then you
can actually manually assign jobs to
independent clusters if for example you
knew one user which was supposed to run
on just one cluster you can mandate that
they only run on that cluster or you can
allow the Federation to allocate that
job and how that works is that the the
Federation actually submits the job to
all the clusters right so all the
clusters get a view of this job and
whichever cluster responds that it have
that it can allocate the job the fastest
is given that job and all of the other
clusters delete that job replica right
so a great way to distribute jobs
automatically according to whatever is
able to respond to quickest so this is
really great like I said for burst of
cloud use cases a lot of customers have
already started doing that and it's it's
you know really easy to get started it's
literally one line and your slurm
configuration you restart the daemons
and you're up and running so it's it's
really easy to get started there will be
a code lab on Federation that's linked
from the auto scaling code lab as well
very shortly
another example is HT Condor so this is
a really popular workload manager that's
specifically designed for high
throughput computing the kind of high
throughput computing that Emma
introduced earlier and so it's really
easily deployed on Google cloud platform
using our deployment manager so we have
a tutorial there at that link you can
also just google search google HT condor
tutorial and it will walk you through
the whole process of downloading the
deployment manager scripts installing
them and launching a HT condor cluster
as well as running a job on them so now
I'd like to go into some case studies so
to show you the the power of HT condor
in the cloud we actually have a great
case study so Fermilab is a National
Laboratory that does research into
high-energy particle physics for anybody
who's not familiar with them they're
based in near Chicago
and so they do a lot of work with groups
like CERN and other particle physics and
particle accelerator groups and so the
the what they did was at Super competing
2016 during the week of the show on the
show floor in fact they burst there they
burst their resources by double using
Google cloud platform
so in order to accommodate the as you
can imagine a massive amounts of
computing that they do they built
something called hep cloud a cheapy
cloud high-energy physics cloud and so
this cloud is really a portal designed
to coalesce a lot of disparate computing
resources so they borrow computing time
from exceed and NCSA and a lot of large
supercomputing centers and put it all
together in this hep cloud to run their
jobs since they're so large and they
decided to use GCP to burst so they
actually burst in a very traditional
bursty workload a nine-to-five pattern
right where they see their researchers
coming in and doing their work and they
doubled their compute resources from
160,000 cores to 320,000 cores during
that nine to five all week and they were
able to do this really cost-effectively
for only about fourteen hundred dollars
an hour because of the preemptable VMS
and custom machine types that we have
available on google cloud so if you'd
like to learn a little bit more about
this and see architecture diagrams and
everything like that where they describe
how they did this and there's a great
talk from last year's next called
large-scale and batch computing on
Google compute engine it's really
interesting to have a Fermilab engineer
there to present just to give you an
idea this is the this is the project
they did it's called the CMS detector
it's basically a fifteen or fourteen
hundred fourteen thousand ton 1 million
micro pixel 1 million pixel digital
camera and it captures about 40 million
images a second so you can imagine the
amount of data that generates in the
amount of processing that takes another
great example is our friends Andrew
Sutherland at MIT
he's a mathematics professor and
researcher and so he was exploring the
generalization of hyper elliptic curves
it's a math problem and so he needed a
really large amount of compute resources
to do this work and so MIT being MIT
they have some HPC resources so he went
to them and he said I need I need a lot
of a lot of nodes a lot of cores to do
this job and I need some very specific
software and they weren't able to
accommodate him so he needed to go to
Google Cloud and at first as you can see
in the blog post on the bottom he spun
up 220,000 cores for a single job it
likes to break his own records though I
guess so the next job II ran he hit 500
80,000 cores in a single job using
preemptable VMS and he did this on 32
core instances 618 thousand of them or
so that came to about 300 computer core
years of compute and he did this using
preemptable VMS so he set up
checkpointing on the local disks so that
when the node was preempted when I
noticed preempted it's just stopped so
you can restart the node and if it's
check pointed to disk your resume from
the checkpoint and off you go right so
very efficient way to do that
computation he said it changes your
whole outlook on research when you can
ask a question and get an answer in
hours rather than months or weeks right
you start to really ask different
questions and that's really true the
reason he did that five hundred eighty
thousand core job is because he decided
to expand his problem space tremendously
to not look at just the traditional
curves to put but to look at any curves
and he got some interesting results out
of that so you can read more about that
in the blog
to the bottom so what is 300 years Corie
years rather of compute time look like
in a few hours well there you have it
and the best part of this is that he
actually launched this on a Sunday
afternoon sitting on his back porch and
it costs less than the amount of money
he expected it to cost and gotten his
grant shaumbra J is another great
example slumbers day for anybody who's
not familiar with them as an oil and gas
exploration company and so they migrated
their compute resources to Google cloud
to meet their massive demand so what's
Lumbridge a does is really sends out
ships into the ocean with massive
trawler signal arrays and and data
capture arrays and they use all of that
data to create visualizations of the
Seas subsurface to find these oil
deposits and tell other people where to
drill and so by using these their custom
machine types and NVIDIA GPUs they were
able to hit about 35 petaflop sub
compute power and 10 petabytes of
storage and Google cloud platform
there's a great talk as well from next
17 called supercharger performance using
GPUs in the cloud and during that a
shock belani the executive vice
president of technology at slumber J
said they're leveraging the strengths
offered by cloud computation to bring
their data processing to the next level
and finally we have silicon therapeutics
they're a drug discovery company based
in Cambridge Massachusetts and so they
shifted their compute to run on GC P and
they by doing so we're able to find many
more active compounds than they were
able to previously so in the blog post
at the bottom of the slide there they
said the biggest benefit of using GCP
was being able to more thoroughly screen
compounds than they ever could have
before with their in-house resources and
that it allowed them the massive amount
of compute resources available in the
cloud allowed them to find more active
compounds than they ever would have been
able to find previously which means that
they could probably find more active
drugs
so they hit about 16,000 cores and three
million core hours for only $30,000
again this is because of preemptable VMS
and custom machine types they actually
used a mix of standard and preemptable
VMs which is very popular so the
standard VMS were used for the longer
running and Static portions of their
jobs some of those were coordinating
jobs where they would launch my you know
sub jobs or minor jobs and then coalesce
all the results back and launch more
jobs again off of that and then use
preemptable VMS for the shorter
independant jobs so they chose google
cloud because of our skylake processors
our fast local SSDs are commitment to
open source and of course that crazy
pricing so I'd like to offer you guys
the chance to look up some of these blog
posts and a few more that I didn't
mention on things like satellite image
processing and genomics and we also have
some great talks this week at soup that
next 18 the the top one actually
happened already but all of our sessions
will be recorded and available on
YouTube very quickly actually
yesterday's sessions are available today
but we do have two more coming up so
research workloads on preemptable VMs is
about doing computing on preemptable VMs
really taking advantage of them and
that's with one of our product managers
and a couple of people from two sigma
financial services customer as well as
competing with power not previously
possible with bigquery and compute
engine this is actually touching on
slurm specifically so SUNY Downstate
Medical Center in University South
Carolina are using slurm auto scaling
clusters in the cloud to run their
neuroscience research and genomics
research respectively and they'll be
talking on a panel tomorrow so that's
all I had does anybody have any
questions if not please dig into those
code labs and tutorials
[Music]